personne sort ici en perdant trois
sahraouis comme gagnant face ils
voulaient l'hexagone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'ai vraiment aimé mon expérience
les gens qui
je suis pas anodine de christine
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup dans les populations
défavorisées
pourquoi ces des équipes
pourquoi ce nom le juge et la finance
à ses côtés un serveur l'habitude et un
rose pour garder l'ambiance
j'suis trop balancé comme le test c'est
comme l'examen après les pratiques
une fois que tu appelles tu es ce que tu
cognes qui espère qu est ce qui va
toujours gagner de l'expérience et cette
expérience leur cela ramène en pratique
il tâte un goal 8
les balancer comme ce challenge quoi
mène actuellement en tournée qui sévit
aussi adidas a joué pratiquement toute
l'année qui s'apprennent le ballon c'est
la seule chine et y en a qui vivent de
ce long voyage intervient juste devoir
passer par la culture hip hop qui y voit
beaucoup à la télé c'est quoi les
efforts en terme de musique en train
fantôme de lifestyle mais yo yo une
chose que gasquet s'incline donc c'est
toute une culture du prix famille c'est
tout un espoir sur montréal aura
beaucoup de bionis tara danse urbaine a
beaucoup de ce nombre de compagnies de
danse ménages sont mêmes chances
donc c'est important qu'ils voient ces
gens là qui voit que c'est le beau temps
qu'un juge mes chorégraphies d'antin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vraiment aimé soeur puis jérémy
père mieux mais je suis plus à prendre
[Applaudissements]
j'aime vraiment pas les barreaux parce
que j'ai vraiment aimé ça paraît
peut-être mais ce que j'aime c'est
vraiment les spectateurs mais les
barreaux ça m'amène à explorer c'est
vrai là dedans c'est un peu comme ma
liberté c'est la manière qui est
m'exprime cerbère que j'ai appris à
m'exprimer
donc je suis resté là d'anticiper les
mutations
et l'agencé tap m et supprimera temps je
voulais en faire un axe man que prix
pour tous non pas chaud